-Performing his hit "All Mine"
from his album "Wasteland,"
give it up for Brent Faiyaz,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ You know how it feels ♪
-♪ All mine, all mine ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ Yeah, it's all mine ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ All mine, all mine ♪
-♪ Baby, let's keep it real ♪
♪ We both still young
so what's the rush? ♪
♪ The night is young
and we not drunk enough ♪
♪ You come around
if I don't do too much ♪
♪ We had our downs
but we had way more ups ♪
♪ Let's make love ♪
♪ That be the reason that you
always hit me up you ♪
♪ I swear you like the way
I 'cause I get rough ♪
♪ You told me your new man
don't make you ♪
♪ That's a damn shame ♪
♪ You come here, I'll knock
your out the damn frame ♪
♪ Remember that last time I made
you miss your damn plane ♪
♪ Remember that last time I wet
you down with champagne ♪
♪ Remember that and I know I've
been the worst ♪
♪ But I love you better ♪
♪ If you let me ♪
♪ Let's catch a flight,
change the weather ♪
♪ And I promise forever ♪
-♪ All mine, all mine ♪
-♪ All mine, yeah, yeah ♪
-♪ You know how it feels ♪
♪ You know how it feels ♪
♪ To be mine ♪
♪ You're mine ♪
♪ Baby, let's keep it real ♪
♪ If only I could pay the bills
with my love for you ♪
♪ We'd be the richest
in the room ♪
♪ Yeah, we'd be so comfortable ♪
♪ Girl, it's only you for me ♪
♪ No lie ♪
♪ I'll drop what they offered ♪
♪ They're not who I want them
to be ♪
♪ That's not an offer to me ♪
♪ If you're around, baby ♪
♪ When you ain't with me,
you feel alone ♪
♪ And I was wonderin' if you've
always known ♪
♪ You don't have to be perfect ♪
♪ I feel like it's worth it ♪
♪ I know now that I've been
the worst ♪
♪ But I love you better ♪
♪ If you let me ♪
♪ Let's catch a flight,
change the weather ♪
♪ And I promise forever ♪
-♪ All mine, all mine ♪
-♪ All mine ♪
♪ Mine, mine, mine, mine ♪
-♪ All mine, all mine ♪
-♪ You know how it feels ♪
♪ Mine ♪
-♪ All mine, all mine ♪
-♪ Mine ♪
♪♪
♪ Baby, let's keep it real ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]